okay all right now for this
last part here this last part here um i
didn't trust myself to draw these
accurately live so i've already drawn
them and i'm just going to reveal them
to you but i just want you to think
about whether you can anticipate what
things are
fitting in this gap over here on the
right hand side okay
um for example you actually um know
what's going to go here in the middle
think about this
this is stationary it's stationary so
you know it's going to be like sort of
horizontally right and also
there's no concavity at this particular
point
but it's not just a straight line i've
already drawn one of those okay
have a think about this it's not a
maximum turning point
it's not a minimum turning point what's
the other kind of thing you can get when
you have a stationary point we have
another it's a very long awkward name
yeah they kind of wiggle a bit right
okay they got a long awkward name
we call these guys does this picture
make sense of it for you
do you remember what's the long awkward
name it's a
horizontal point
of inflection it's a long name right
[Music]
okay now these horizontal points of
inflection right we had to introduce
them to you first
because they are related to stationary
points which we learned about
a while ago okay but i wonder if any of
you
kind of suspected if there are
horizontal points of inflection
then are there other kinds of points of
inflection that aren't horizontal
and the answer is yes you can have
points in reflection that are not
horizontal they might be
increasing they're going to look like
this
now have a look at the top
okay uh i'm going to leave all of this
here so you have the time to read it
right i want you to look at them okay
we looked at this last week when i
showed you that pandemic curve
in i think it was guangdong was the name
of the province right do you remember
there was a point where the curve looked
exponential
and then we were like oh it starts
slowing down and starts looking
logarithmic so it's um which one is that
it's this one over here do you see that
right it's like oh it's super steep but
then at a certain point
it's sort of it's still increasing but
it sort of starts to increase at a
slower rate
okay so that's what you got on the left
um you could have a nightmare situation
over here on the right where things
start off slow but then you're like oh
no
we didn't do any social distancing we
didn't do any testing
so the pendant we just got worse and
worse and worse so you can see it
skyrocketing over there on the right
hand side
both of these are what we call points of
inflection okay
now these are increasing points of
inflection because if you have a look
i've showed it in gray there
have a look at the gradient at the point
of inflection
do you notice the gradients are both
going up do you see that
so they're not horizontal points of
inflection they're increasing which is
why they belong in that top row
sophie it's like
i don't know um if they curve yep yep
they have
some kind of okay very good so
this is very sneaky right because the
graphs are curved
a lot of the parts of this graph do have
concavity i'll show you for example
um i've even drawn it see why am i blue
there we go
um see this part here right it's concave
up i've even shown the arrow right here
to show you it's concave up
but that's why i've drawn the dot right
there see at that
one spot right there it's not any
concavity this part is concave up
this part is concave down right smack
bang in the middle
it's neither it is neither concave up
nor concave down um same deal here
right see that one spot in the middle
it's not concave up
it's not concave down it's it's between
those two concavities
right right so that's why you can see
over here these guys are straight lines
the whole thing has no concavity right
but for these guys over here there's
just one little brief moment
where there's no concavity right it's
just the one where i put the dot
finally i'll do the bottom right these
are still points of inflection but
they're not increasing
um they're decreasing right so i'll just
complete it there for you
um it's the same thing but in reverse
right they're going down
can you see can you make out those gray
lines there they're all heading
downwards because the gradient
is negative okay so everything you can
see
um in this little sort of semi-column in
here
these are all different varieties
of points of
inflection
i know there's a lot on here
when um i know this is gonna sound weird
but when i started my teaching career
i used to teach students about this and
i only taught them about some parts
of the table in fact only about the the
extreme corners so there's four corners
right
i only showed them those and then when
students started to encounter different
things
they'd be like mr wu you didn't tell us
about this thing and i was like oh yeah
i didn't
sorry um and so even though there's a
large variety here there's like a zoo of
different kinds of
functions and how they behave you will
encounter each of them one at a time at
different parts of different grasps i
hope it helps you make sense of it
okay